on venait d'arriver à berlin puis à
l'ifa qui est débute demain enfin pas
exactement demain vendredi lé media day
ce qui commence demain pendant deux
jours à l'ifa peu importe on va parler
de l'ifan dans les jours à venir pour
l'instant cela fonctionne je voulais
vous parler d'un casque qu'on m'a
proposé était sèche ça plutôt cool
c'est ce petit casque la seule au 3 ou
wire laisse de beats by dr dre alors
vous n'êtes pas sans savoir que la boîte
était rachetée par apple et quelques
années et qui propose des casques cool
design cible jeune clairement assumé et
qui en tout cas ma connaissance
intéressant que j'étais c'est donc à
quelques années allez un petit peu trop
sur le graphe c'était un peu ce que je
reprochais en tout cas voilà c'est qu'à
ce collage les prix il est là je
l'essayé depuis quelques temps je vous
dirai ce que j'en pense à ce qu'il est
intéressant oui non pas comment ça un
produit qui est en tout cas je trouve
cool déjà d'un point de vue comment
esthétique qui a un positionnement
marketing qui vraiment assumer une cible
plutôt jeune cast pas hyper cher plutôt
pas mal
est-ce qu'il est à la hauteur vous n'ont
pas commencé son regard maintenant
[Musique]
beaucoup déjà clairement ce qui est cool
la première chose c'est je dirais le
design de ce casque moi je trouve plutôt
bien réussir il ya plein de couleurs
différentes ce qui assume et clairement
là dessus c'est qu'on va avoir un casque
pour un public je dirais à ces jeunes
des couleurs éclatantes qui pète qui
sont bien coordonné ce blouson rouge
s'installant il ya plein d'autres
couleurs au catalogue ce qui vous
intéresse vous invite à jeter un petit
coup d'ailleurs je vous ai mis un lien à
des liens va dans la description et je
trouve cool
vraiment on le voit un les couleurs
c'est une cible jeune ce qui est
vraiment cool c'est la passion explique
petit arceaux comme ça très facile
facile à mettre dans une petite pochette
je voudrais cependant quelques instants
je vais vous montrer la boîte le contenu
est bien bien travaillé bien packagée ça
c'est bien
et le point qui est intéressant c'est la
mise en place là alors déjà quand vous
mettez tout de suite il ya une isolation
passive c'est à dire ça à venir un petit
peu bouché le canal de mes oreilles ça
sert un peu donc on sent une petite
pression qui s'exécute en tout cas sur
les oreilles le point un peu positif
effectivement mais ça vous isole donc ça
protège un petit peu des bruits
environnants
maintenant le truc c'est que c'est pas
non plus le top du confort on sent un
petit peu ici là c'est petit parti qui
est en en espèces de caoutchouc au
niveau de la tête le bouger pathos oncle
bougeait pas de trop sans quoi ça frotte
un peu les cheveux mais bon après on s'y
habitue
ça dépend comment vous le sert et moi
personnellement je sers pas trop un tout
petit peu mais pas trop comme ça il n'y
a pas de points de pression là bon c'est
pas le casque plus confortable que j'ai
pu tester mais bon dans l'absolu je
trouve pas mal de ce point de vue là
autre point qui est cool et non des
moindres c'est vous avez une vraie
flexibilité au niveau de l'arceau dont
qui bouge ça se déplace bien bons rails
et pratique est assez souple ça je
trouve que voilà une belle finition
produit qui est bien un qu'on peut
vraiment ni réglée à la tête de chacun
qui voudraient une toute petite est une
très grande peine voilée record de la
main vous pourrez vous pouvez en passer
il va s'adapter à toutes les
morphologies donc ça c'est gérer un
point vraiment important et intéressant
on va se décaler l'âge et le soleil à
l'ats que ce soit un peu mieux je n'ai
pas une espèce de truc dans la tronche
autre point qui est cool c'est que vous
avez de la mousse à mémoire de forme qui
situent juste ici au niveau des coussins
donc excusez-moi l'enel seraient en
pleine tronche les terrains change c'est
un peu l'aventuré pas du tout dans le
studio là je suis à berlin je suis
arrivé à l'hôtel et là j'ai un petit
coucher de soleil donc forcément j'ai
tout par la tête mais ça c'est plutôt
bien comme ça on éclaire et ses
pratiques s'écoute donc je vous disais
l'ergonomie est bien le fait d'abord
cette mousse à mémoire de forme je
trouve que sarah donne vraiment ça va
vraiment venir
rajoutez pas si vous voyez bien au
confort bon ça marche il ya un côté un
petit peu faux cuir dessus que je trouve
très sympa après mais je trouve que d'un
point de vue global
il ya un vrai aspect premium sur ce
casque les boutons parce que vous avez
des boutons oui ils sont situés ici
alors n'attendez l'âge et la gauche
l'âge et la droite ici sur la gauche l'a
en fait je vais avoir déjà un premier
bouton ici qui va être le bouton play
pause décrocher raccrocher si vous
appuyez deux ou trois fois ça va faire
un morceau suivant morceau précédent sur
le dessus là vous avez un petit bouton
pour monter le volume mais c'est drôle
c'est très intuitif quoi c'est bien de
bien penser de la part de beats sur le
côté droit vous n'avez absolument aucun
bouton vous allez voir juste un petit
bouton qui situent juste là qui est
plutôt pour venir l'allumer et pour
venir les talents et lorsque vous
l'allumez bien vous avez des petites led
qui vont apparaître qu'ils sont en fait
les indications de batteries qui vous
dira c'est pas ce casque est chargé oui
ils n'ont donc ça c'est plutôt bien
vous avez de la connectique et si pour
lunel recharger au micro usb ça marche
se recharge rapidement d'ailleurs
bientôt qui ne fâche m'en vais là dessus
je vous lis dans quelques instants
et dès qu'il est allumé voyez up email
marque connecter tout de suite il se
reconnaît automatiquement quoi c'est
vrai peuple qui est vraiment cool et
justement l'appareillage est très très
très simple ça je vous en parle juste
après et de l'autre côté vous avez ici
une petite prise en jack jack 3.5 pour
venir le brancher directement si vous
voulez pas attendre à latence parce que
oui forcément sans casque bluetooth et
bien moment ou un autre on avait la
tente donc le tout est vraiment bien
bien finie boccace facile à utiliser les
collectifs sang coule donc de ce point
de vue là c'est vachement bien
laissez-moi vous montrer la boîte c'est
savoir moi je sens que c'est quand même
une fois de plus assez efficace c'est on
le voit la cible et jeu dans la côté
bleu blanc rouge en plus que ça parle ça
dépend bien évidemment du modèle que
vous allez prendre un beau soleil même
pas le jeu mais là ça marche bien c'est
plutôt cool
l'ouverture c'est comme ça alors
attention il faut appuyer d'un côté ou
de l'autre pour le sortir il faut savoir
lui parlez vous enlevez autre petit
écrin alors normalement vous n'avez pas
ça c'était sur mes écouteurs jeu les
laisser ici
voyez vous arrivez avec le logo donc
plutôt sympa entre effectivement
l'ouverture avec le petit logo vous
lever et là vous arrivez sur la partie
changed the way you were sent donc ça
c'est cool logoté très jolie vous avez
si cette petite partie vous venez
l'ouvrir et la regarder tout arrive
alors normalement ça s'est pas posé à
l'arraché mois qu'il est mais c'est
comme ça
vous avez votre casque qui est posée là
dedans donc on avait un étui pour venir
le balader et c'est ça qui est cool
aussi voyez c'est qu'ils se replient
extrêmement facilement vous leur mettez
dans vous refermez et vous avez votre
casque en mode nomade vous pouvez venir
vous balader où vous voulez donc ça
c'est vraiment cool
ensuite à l'intérieur vous allez avoir
en dessous et bien toute une partie mais
voir je vous montre ça voilà vous allez
avoir essayé votre petit câble de charge
que moi j'ai ressorti qui normalement
est ici vous avez un petit mousquetons
bits ce qui est tout mignon tout sympa
tout joli ensuite à l'intérieur vous
allez vous retrouver ici avec des infos
concernant votre casque comment il
marche comment l'allument comment le
connais bien évidemment petit
autocollant pour vous venez faire un
petit peu de pub pour le mettre sur vos
affaires et pillé toutes les
informations légales et compagnie sur
votre casse d'envoyer bon il ya
l'essentiel ça marche on va parler tout
de suite de l'audio la qualité le truc
effectivement que moi je l'attend un
petit peu reproché habitent sont des
casques sont extrêmement flatteur dans
les graves qui tout de suite lorsque
vous les lutteurs vous mettez la musique
il y en a pas sinon j'ai eu du mal à me
concentrer à vous parler mais lorsqu'on
était la musique est là tout de suite
c'est un peu ça va ronronner ça va
rajouter vraiment du grave vous n'allez
pas avoir un son naturel vous n'êtes pas
voir son flat voulait pouvoir dire
travailler qu un équaliseur en
équaliseur vous pourrez l'utiliser si
vous avez les applications dédiées genre
spotify vous pouvez faire des petits éco
liseur mais bon voilà faut savoir que
dès le départ
le son est vraiment flatteur vraiment
flatteur dans les graves dans les basses
fréquences medium grade je dirais que
entre 0 et commence à vous l'entendez
pas vous n'aurez pas mais aller entre 50
hertz à 200 m
on est un petit peu flatté après tout ce
qui va être un peu plus ce médium grave
entre 250 et 1 800 m on est quand même
un peu flatteur alors après le côté
intéressant c'est que si vous écoutez du
hip hop si vous écoutez de la musique
électronique
et si vous voulez que ça ronronne un peu
et mal là franchement vous serez hyper
hyper hyper heureux ou heureuse
le rnb c'est la même chose c'est cool
donc ça c'est le côté un peu pratique
c'est de gérer l avantage de cuques de
ce casque mais par contre si vous
l'écoutez un truc vraiment jazz à bord
une musique flatter profiter vraiment du
boulot qui a été fait par les ingénieurs
du son au niveau de la conception de la
musique et bien vous n'êtes pas
forcément c'est justement pas un casque
est vraiment destiné aux audiophiles
pure qui veulent écouter la restitution
parfaite de la musique c'est un casque
pour un public jeune un public plutôt à
mon avis urbain qui veut écouter de la
musique actuelle la la musique plus
électro de la musique qui vend tout cas
se satisfaire d'avoir du son qui
envoient plus de bois même pourquoi pas
du métal ça envoie du bois en êtes vous
avez des bonnes bases derrière qui
tartinent c'est toujours c'est toujours
assez cool à côté ça ça veut pas dire
que le son qui est plus haut qui va être
médium au médium alors qu'ils allaient
rendre les aigus n'existe pas c'est pas
vrai tout est assez précis en fait même
quand vous écoutez dès des bruits de
deux cymbales vous les avez mais par
contre des fois elles sont un petit peu
étouffé par le fait justement vous ayez
et bien c'est son basque son petit peu
trop omniprésent moi c'est un peu le
truc à côté de ça les les médiums sont
pas mal je vous êtes assez précis voilà
ça n'est pas en retraite plus du style
de musique que vous allez écouter et si
ça va ronronner en aimant ou pas mais je
peux pas dire que le son est mauvais le
son est plutôt cool mais il faut
vraiment savoir qu'en achetant ce casque
est bien le fait que vous ayez du grave
de là bas ça fait partie de son adn donc
ça il faut vraiment le savoir c'est très
très très important à côté de ça demande
une fois de plus pour écouter des
morceaux qui justement sont mis en
valeur par ce type de fréquences va ça
marche ça marche même plutôt bien le
casque est assez puissant ne pas la
peine d'écouter hyper fort pour se
rendre sourd mais ça marche quand même
relativement puissant si vous avez de la
latence sens que vous allez écouter en
vous tous vous avez une toute petite
latence personnellement je trouve pas du
tout déconnante et dérangeante vous
allez pouvoir regarder une série garde
un fil en bluetooth avec votre casse ça
fonctionne bien
la latence est extrêmement minime si
vous n'en voulez pas vous allez le
brancher ici avec la prise jack ça
marchera aussi parfaitement bien ça sera
même d'ailleurs beaucoup mieux sans
latence par contre ici il faut le savoir
y a pas de haute résolution pas de erez
ici il y en a pas mais c'est pas non
plus très grave c'est parce qu'on venir
rechercher avec ce casque beats une
boîte qui appartient à apple et du coup
on a une connexion t extrêmement facile
comme ça vous allez pouvoir retrouver
notamment que l'airpod c'est à dire que
vous avez votre iphone si vous avez un
iphone vous allumez et il a proposé de
l'appareil est directement extrêmement
faciles en contre ça c'est lent
extrêmement positif
deuxième point et non des moindres pour
utiliser sur android vous avez une
application vous la télécharger ils
peuvent vous l'avez télécharger vos
adoubé casque c'est pareil ils se
reconnaissent appareil très rapide c'est
pratique c'est sympa ça marche très bien
pendant l'application n'apprend pas
grand chose on voit son niveau de
batterie si oracle casque est collecté
on peut venir si on le souhaite le
renommé ici on axe à quelques-uns
confident l'enregistrer mais dans
l'absolu il n'y a pas grand chose dans
cette application peut venir ajouter un
nouvel appareil beat si vous le
souhaitez pour venir
l'application pour des réglages de
l'application n'y a pas grand chose vous
avez vos réglages android qui sont
situées juste là mais on n'y a pas grand
chose à faire là dessus vous voyez si
vous voulez analyse et confidentialité
envoyer les informations directement
pour optimiser les mentions légales
ensuite parcourir beats pour découvrir
un petit peu toute la gamme que vous
allez pouvoir retrouver
bon voilà pourquoi pas pour moi
d'applications certes pas grand chose si
ce n'est pouvoir le connecter la
première fois vous allez vouloir
l'utiliser
maintenant il ya une loi qui libère
intéressant c'est l'autonomie vous avez
retenu mais qui renonce et jusqu'à 40
heures alors par rapport à la génération
précédente ya un pas énorme qui a été
fait jusqu'à 40 heures je pourrais pas
vous le dire je n'ai pas mesuré que le
chronomètre en main mais c'est vrai que
personnellement je suis pas encore
arrivé au bout de ce casque est l'autre
point qui fâche beaucoup c'est que vous
avez la fuel charge est de la recharge
extrêmement rapide en cinq minutes des
partis un peu plus de deux heures
musique donc ça c'est vraiment cool
si en gros vous avez oublié leurs
chargeurs dit mince j'ai pas le temps
vous pleurez cinq minutes et vous serez
parti pour des heures musique donc ça
c'est vraiment hyper cool et c'est pour
moi un des points extrêmement positif de
ce casque maintenant qu un peu négatif
et bien il n'y a pas de certification
éco-certifié contre la puise
éclaboussures et compagnie après côté de
ça s'il va rencontrer un petit peu d'eau
comme ça vous inquiétez pas il va pas se
mettre à cette année à crâner ça devrait
quand même plutôt bien se passer
5 est mort tellement j'aime bien il
annoncé au tarif de 199 euros 95 sur le
site de beats un petit peu cher là
dessus vous trouverez moins cher vous ai
mis des liens dans la description si
vous voulez l'acquérir au meilleur tarif
allez jeter un petit coup d'oeil vers
vachement cool c'est pour moi un casque
qui est hyper efficace qui est sans
compromis une belle amélioration par
rapport aux générations précédentes qui
est plutôt bien tu vas pas être le
casque le plus conforme et qui n'est pas
non plus le cast le plus cher qui est un
casque qui à qui est destiné à un public
jeune qui est très clairement destiné
public un peu plus jeune
de par le travail qui est fait au niveau
de l'audio le fait d'avoir ce qu il
ronronne un peu plus mais à côté de ça
ça marche bien donc si vous voulez un
casque qui à la fois joli bien pratique
qui va ronronner qui vont envoyer du
steak sur les fréquences un peu plus
grave est bien là dessus mon avis vous
serez absolument pas du sud
bon et bien voilà donc c'est tout pour
cette première journée à berlin je vous
monte vite fait dans la piaule je suis
déjà venu les dernières dans cet hôtel
hôtel for youth la dernière j'avais une
belle salle de bain avec une grande
baignoire cette année c'est pas le cas
pour ce que t'es marrant l'année
dernière c'est que en faille dans la
salle de bain eh bien vous avez des
grands rideaux tout vous pouvez venir
vous
donc si vous ne seriez pas les rideaux
bien bye bye l'endroit est tenu là par
contre voyage à une petite douche c'est
plus petit c'est cosy mais c'est très
mignon
donc voilà donc là c'est pour ce soir
parce que demain je change d'hôtel après
demain demain y'a vraiment de notre
hôtel et après après demain je reviens
ici pour deux ou trois c'est cool c'est
l'aventuré c'est sympa sur ce je vous
fais des gros becs 1
et puis vous donne rendez vous demain
matin
[Musique]